uh interesting piece there yes
pulling in chief meteorologist ted
florento he's brought some notes oh my
gosh the girl scout cookies boy girl
scout cookies there goes my diet you
know what eric agather used to go around
with his daughters he got like 60 people
to sign up i remember those now you're
taking over that role aren't you
absolutely i am
lauren our producer got like 11 boxes
so
all right i'll fill it up thank you
for you guys right thank you
coming off a diet story i apologize i
apologize about that but it's girl scout
season right so you're going to see all
those boxes out there great shot tonight
of the las vegas strip this is looking
for a moleski corporate tower cam
looking at the strip with clouds have
increased across the region after some
clearing earlier today we're going to
see more clouds tonight 59 degrees
our high for the day today or at least
not official but that could be our high
we're going to wait to see what the
weather service says that puts us right
near average the record 74 degrees set
back at two thousand kirsten isn't
kidding but she's filling out that
already
the bride's next
christian i saw you email me earlier
today 43 degrees overnight for the low
53 in summerlin 58 first for centennials
59 for the lake 61 downtown where the
mid 60's sunrise matter green valley 61.
58 for henderson and 57 for you in
southern highlands 56 seven hills and
also saint rose parkway there 61 prompt
along along with sandy valley boulder
city and mesquite included in that in 66
for laughlin so radar network not
showing anything here all that action
seems to be spotty showers way off into
southern california now that's not
creating any flooding this is this light
shower activity like we said very
scattered at this point this all coming
off that low that's just been sitting
out for the california the past week now
moving onshore so we're going to keep
our eye on shower chances now this is a
futurecast for right around 8 news now
at 11 and midnight where most of it
really be west of us but we get to
midnight after midnight and that
increases tomorrow morning now again
nothing widespread very isolated and
then it clears out fairly quickly by
midday and the afternoon closer look
right now the shower chances again
very isolated and if we get anything at
all it will be very brief and that is
for tomorrow morning which could be
during the commute but again we're
looking at slight shower chances we'll
see what the latest update says for
eight news nine eleven tonight we'll
have another update then best chances
will be between 2 a.m and 9 a.m
not expecting measurable rain anything
could be anything pops up will be
isolated and very brief like you saw in
that future cast so 46 overnight
increasing clouds
slight shower chances after midnight 60
degrees tomorrow clouds and then
sunshine later isolated showers like we
said in the morning hours mainly eight
day forecast shows temperatures and
those low 60's after tomorrow breezy
friday and saturday plenty of sunshine
after that you guys are really filling
out that
that forum for the girl scouts i
appreciate that back over to you
this is stressful there's a lot of
options here there are you can have one
of each
all right the five o'clock news is
coming right up let's check it now with
brian loftus who smelled cookies and
headed over here in studio
never stopped writing the entire weather
before i mean just are there any cookies
left we'll find out